this week as parents across the country
protest
cruel scientifically illiterate mask
mandates for kids
biden's hapless education secretary
miguel cardona
threatened school closures in response
and biden himself weighed in
against kids against parents and against
science
in rhode island the teachers union is
suing a parent
for the crime of trying to find out
exactly what kind of woke
poison the schools are spewing into the
minds of her children
all while the unions once again hold
america's children hostage
with threats to close schools unless
their preposterous pandemic demands are
met
what does all this show that the people
who should have the power
when it comes to education parents have
had it taken away
by an unholy alliance of the teachers
unions and the education bureaucracy
from the start of this pandemic the
teachers unions knew the virus barely
affected children
yet they exploited it for their own
political and personal benefit
closing schools in america while
countries around the world opened theirs
up in some cases barely closing at all
political demands like wealth taxes
charter school bans medicare for all
the evil push for hateful divisive
brainwashing
dangerous race-baiting ideologue
ibrahmax candy headlining their
conference
the leaders of the two biggest teachers
unions proudly defending
racism and woke indoctrination the
teachers unions are the biggest
opportunity crushes in america
sacrificing educational standards and
student achievement
for political dogma that dumbs
everything down
all while demanding more money less work
lavish pensions in california getting
five thousand dollar bonuses seven
percent salary bumps and retroactive pay
raises
just for showing up how are the teachers
unions
obviously america's public enemy number
one
winning like this corruption is a big
part of it for
years the unions have bribed and bribed
and bribed again new york state united
over 13 million dollars to democrats in
california
over 14 million at the national level
over 60 million
dollars to democrats and what has
america got in exchange
as even a liberal columnist in the new
york times points out
greeks have higher high school
graduation rates
15 year olds in russia poland latvia and
many other countries
are better at math than their american
counterparts one-fifth
of american fifteen-year-olds can't read
at the level expected of a ten-year-old
the performance of the union run public
school system
has been a complete catastrophe and of
course
hardest hit are the communities that
democrats and the teacher unions claim
they care about
a new report found native american third
graders performed
14 lower in math this year compared to
2019
black students 15 points lower latino
students
17 points lower in majority black
baltimore
close to half the kids got a gpa
of below 1.0 in california public
schools
there's the equivalent of a four year
achievement gap
between black and white eighth grade
students but bad as the teachers unions
are they're not the only reason
for this monumental and humiliating
failure to properly educate our children
in every state and local area public
school bureaucracies
are in charge of the system presiding
over this national disaster
in baltimore they have an achievement
and accountability office
in baltimore where kids are in the
public school system for a decade
and nearly half of them barely get any
education at all
but every single bureaucrat in the
achievement and accountability office
gets over a hundred thousand dollars a
year so
when the democrats blame republicans
blame
racism blame anyone but themselves for
the poverty
the inequality the racial injustice that
is all too common
in the exact places they run we say no
it's not
racism it's not republicans it's you the
useless
incompetent ideological unaccountable
education bureaucrats paying yourselves
a fortune
from public money you're the ones
destroying the lives of some of the
least advantaged kids in america
in california superintendent michael
lynn at corona norco unified
paid nearly half a million dollars when
less than half the kids are even
proficient in math
in red states too as we showed you last
week with the mississippi fat cats
report
local school bureaucrats on massive
salaries totally unrelated
to performance on and on it goes bloated
bureaucracies taking our money
failing our children the entire
educational establishment has failed
every single part of it colleges too
where they
incubate appalling teaching theories
like a virus
sent to infect generation after
generation of children
this is the systemic racism kamala
harris this is the structural change we
need elizabeth warren
for years we've stood by watching the
public school system crumble
endless top-down centralizing reform
from bush's no child left behind to
obama's race to the top
but it's the system that's broken
there's no point reforming it
you don't reform a rotten building you
tear it down and build a new one
some say charter schools are the answer
and yes since the first one was
established in saint paul minnesota in
1992
they have proved their worth ohio
charter school students gained between
35
and 40 extra days of learning in seattle
it's nearly 60 days more learning
students from la charter schools much
more likely
to be eligible for state universities
and their peers in union-run schools
charter schools create ladders of
opportunity for black and latino kids
we've seen that in maryland in newark
new jersey right across the country
in new york city even when the charter
school classes are in the same
buildings as public schools they did
better
charter schools work because they're
independent of the education bureaucracy
and free from the low expectation low
achievement lowest common denominator
woke
madness of the public school system and
most of their teachers aren't unionized
so of course
democrats and their teacher union pay
masters hate them
just the other week pelosi's house
voting to cut 40 million dollars from
the federal charter schools program
for once a spending cut they like in new
york democrat politicians
blocking charter school expansion even
when democrat
residents support it california governor
gavin newsom also supported charter
schools once
then he decided he had to suck up to the
teachers unions to get elected
so in his 2018 campaign he pledged to
close
charters down and once in office gave
districts more power to block them
in exchange millions more dollars from
the unions
of course none of this affects him he
sends his kids to private school just
like so many
leading democrats who know how bad the
public school system is how disgusting
that these democrats deny parents the
exact same choice they deny everyone
else's parents
how sickening that they attack the very
schools that help the people they claim
to speak for
the most republicans by contrast are
pushing forward with school choice
prompted by parent frustration over
pandemic closures just in the last
few months we've seen positive moves in
iowa arizona arkansas
indiana kentucky missouri and new
hampshire all created education savings
accounts that can be used to pay for
private school tuition and give parents
more choice but here's the truth
it's not enough even if all this was
enacted
only a small fraction of america's
children would have access
to these opportunities the vast majority
would be stuck
in the public school system at the mercy
of the teacher unions
and the education bureaucracy and it's
only going to get worse
the union's power is growing not
shrinking
they now have a member in the white
house as biden disgracefully boasted
each year more teachers pour out of
colleges and training institutions
infected with woke-ism
armed to indoctrinate more and more
children what
are we doing fiddling around with
piecemeal reform
a charter school here some fruitling
advance of school choice there
the entire system is rotten it's
dragging america down economically
as our better educated competitors leave
us in the dust it's ripping us apart
socially
as the anti-america brainwashing takes a
deeper and deeper hold
it is the biggest threat we face and
we're running away from it
instead of confronting it enough we know
what works
and we can see what doesn't it is time
for real choice in education
real power in parents hands real reform
not reform in name only it is time to
end
the public school monopoly all the money
the entire
school's budget should be returned to
parents on an equal basis
to spend on the education they think is
best for their child
some kids will thrive in larger schools
others in smaller ones
some in a traditional academic
environment others in something more
creative
thanks to the pandemic there's been an
explosion of innovation
and entrepreneurial energy micro schools
parent-run schools a host of new options
imagine how much more they would be if
education innovators knew they had
every parent in america as a potential
customer
and if we do this if we fund students
not systems
we can finally shut down the disastrous
destructive education establishment and
the local school
bureaucracies this is not a pipe dream
with any luck and
certainly with the support of this show
it could even be on the ballot next year
in my home state
thanks to the california school choice
foundation
let's make this a litmus test for every
republican
running for office close down the school
districts
fire the bureaucrats abolish it all no
more mediocrity
no more critical race theory no more
nonsense from the teacher unions the
educational establishment
and its overpaid underperforming
bureaucrats
power to parents opportunity for kids
success
for america that's the next education
revolution
we need hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else